[Music]
should I do
what sending an emoji okay you cool
welcome to the secret world inside your
phone
we're emojis like me work and live here
each of us does one thing and we have to
nail it every time we are go for men huh
what the heck my friend gene here has a
little problem oh how are you doing that
it's just something I can do please help
us follow me we need to get off the
phone
and find the source code let's roll my
Felicia you need to get the master
password
it was Tina
Karin Sarah I want to say Lupita
but that doesn't feel right now I'm
saying out loud I think you pretty cool
just the way you are
[Music]
my feelings are huge
maybe I meant to have more than just one
of motion crush did by sweet never eat
another piece of candy ever again
high five don't do it don't you do it
it's already been in there once okay son
what do we do after we go potty
should we wash our hands
look who just sent me a text
Eddie McAllister douche she's right
there
that's Alex and like every freshman in
high school his whole life revolves
around his phone what should I write
send her an emoji okay be cool
welcome to the world inside your phone
that's my home
tech stop here each of us does one thing
and we have to nail it every time a
Christmas tree just has to stand there
well festive Christmas it's still
September Tim they just gotta wear their
crowns and keep their hair calm devil
poop thumbs up they just show up and
they're good to go but for the faces the
pressure is on a crier always has to cry
even if he's just won the lottery
laughing even if he's just broken his
arm now me my name is gene I'm a male so
I got to be totally over it all the time
you know like meh who cares which is not
as easy as it sounds I gotta be
I gotta be man
[Music]
Poornima ste oh they're so cute it's
hard to always act as a when living in
text offices just so excited
hello good Simeon's those are some sharp
at essays yes well we have business to
attend to
what kind of business monkey business
[Music]
Hey konnichiwa knocking over the elderly
here let me help let me know Oh like I
have some bad news Jean and I'm afraid
you'll have the wrong reaction okay I'm
not letting you go to work today
wait what you're just not ready son come
on working in the cube is an emoji sole
purpose in life everybody my age is
working on the phone except for me
Oh sweetie that's not true that's
because I believe in you should we wash
our hands you are smooth just doing my
duty
what what did I say come on tell me
you're just a little bit sensitive I
don't want to buy a timeshare come on
man it's high five you know me I'm a
favorite it's got to be some sort of
mistake I mean look at me I'm an
attractive hand giving up I fine
literally look at him I can look like
that my name is Jean and I'm supposed to
be a man man who cares me Jean please
tell me you weren't laughing just now
he's got all the fields looks like it's
gonna be mad okay you can do this
the emoji movie just give me a chance I
can be mad that's really her I was the
original emoji meet smiler there is
nothing like cutting skin for the first
time she's more than a pretty face I
will never make a mistake we know you
won't the first time you said it it's
not a genuine but then you repeated it
and then that that was weird all right
good talk the emoji movie
[Music]
what sending an emoji huh okay are you
cool
welcome to the secret world inside your
phone
we're emojis like me work and live here
each of us does one thing and we have to
nail it every time we are go for meth me
[Music]
what is that
I've got to get this phone fixed this
has never happened before and now alex
has made an appointment to wipe out his
phone it's to leave I'm not gonna run
away from this I made a mistake
but I'm gonna fix it I think we can make
things right we just have to go to a
place where no emoji has gone before
the cloud I know a shortcut through some
apps but no one's ever left our city I
know since after us
[Music]
what is this place the greatest place
ever I've never eaten another piece of
candy again high five don't do it
don't you do it it's already been in
there once we need to get the master
password access denied this might take a
while wait what access denied we're
gonna have some dance our way out
everybody could dance
[Music]
meet high-five
come on man it's high-five you know me
I'm a favorite Oh Chris mom come on in
he's a knucklehead literally he's a
handful another piece of candy ever
again
[Music]
high-five don't do it don't you do it
already been in there one Wow
the emoji movie
[Music]
oh wait a minute you have to get past
this firewall
leaf jailbreak should be smooth sailing
from here you're not gonna see that hair
out of the cube she's the it girl
enter the password I'm a fireball the
emoji movie we're gonna have to dance
our way out
I got no groove everybody can dance I
see now what you are saying
[Music]
hello as you can see I'm an emoji amen
to be exact
any ho it's my pleasure to announce our
first movie yay it's almost too
thrilling for words so bring the family
doesn't have to be your family the emoji
movie so I told management I can't work
like this
these lights I'm mounting in here it's
such a loaded oh no go ahead
finish that sentence come up and see it
this August I'm positively euphoric
right now I might ask you later
[Music]